you know you you had sort of a
I think you had a a reputation or an
image I think and you more than that I
think you just get categorized right you
were a Democrat at the time which I know
you aren't anymore yep uh so what
happened man what happened let's talk
about that so you left the Democratic
party yeah
well first of all just say um
for as long as I've been in politics
people who like to put other humans in
categories have always had trouble
putting me in a category
um just because I've always been a very
independent-minded person so you know I
first ran for office in 2002 in Hawaii I
was 21 years old very passionate about
environmental issues and protecting the
beauty of our home in Hawaii the water
oceans and and that was my motivation to
run for state house and you know prior
to that point I had no
like familial political affiliation
there was no like you know my daddy and
granddaddy were Democrat so I have to be
a Democrat my parents were very like hey
you you go make your own decisions
figure out
you know what what is your foundational
principles and so at that time
I I really had to look because I had to
you know file the piece of paper saying
I'm running for office and there was a
box to check like okay fine what part
are you gonna run under
and so I started looking at um kind of
the origins of in Hawaii the Democratic
party Hawaii had been under the rule of
a few very wealthy Republicans uh since
it became a territory of the United
States and then later through statehood
and the shift towards Democratic
politics in Hawaii came about because
um of Plantation workers people who are
being treated like crap like in in
inhumane conditions being paid pennies
for working
super long hours it was it was basically
like glorified slave labor and so it was
the Democratic party and the ILWU that
came in I was like no this is not okay
and and so it was the party that in our
history in Hawaii was the big tent
inclusive party it was the party for the
people it was the party that stood up
against those few very wealthy people in
power and said no you can't just abuse
people like this uh it was the party
that stood for civil liberties and
individual freedom and choice like hey
whatever your personal choice is whether
it's free speech or freedom of religion
or whatever it is like
Live and Let Live we can disagree
without being disagreeable and so I
looked at the party in Hawaii and I
looked at leaders like JFK and Dr Martin
Luther King and
I was drawn to the Democratic party for
those reasons because again in my as I
looked at Hawaii as like these Super
Rich Republican dudes have been abusing
their power to fill their pockets at the
expense of the well-being of the people
and so fast forward
um
I left the Democrat Party because all of
those things that I just talked about
are gone the leaders of today's
Democratic party don't believe in
um
really into Freedom basically what it
comes down to and you look at that
freedom of choice freedom of speech uh
freedom of religion and
um
you know there's a lot of other issues
that that I could get into But
ultimately how do you have a political
party that's in power
that doesn't believe in Freedom and is
actively taking action to undermine our
Constitution and Bill of Rights
and that was really what was at the the
Crux of of why I left
um the Democrat Party was there a straw
that broke the camel's back
there wasn't one single moment but it
was really over the last like few years
two three years seeing this increasing
um
like quickly escalating towards
um policies coming from our government
that really frankly were becoming
increasingly authoritarian
and so you know it caused me to kind of
spend time reflecting and being
introspective like wait hold on a second
and people saying like how can you still
be how can you call yourself a Democrat
and I was obviously have like I said
I've always been an independent-minded
person I I've been critical of people in
power uh whether they're Republicans Or
democrats and also complimentary when I
felt like they did things that were good
for the country but
um
you know looking looking at at the
dangerous combination of what we've seen
over the last few years especially of
people in power who don't believe in the
Constitution who openly question things
like the first amendment and right to
free speech coupled with oh by the way
they control and are politicizing
agencies like the Department of Justice
and the FBI and Department of Homeland
Security uh sicking the domestic newly
formed domestic Terror unit of the
Department of Homeland Security on
parents like protesting at Board of
Education meetings because they're like
well we don't agree with what you guys
are trying to teach our young kids at
school
and and to see that playing out before
our eyes and this Culture of Fear where
if you speak out against this stuff and
and call it for what it is
you are immediately labeled
anti-authority
and also therefore coming from our
government an extremist and a Potential
Threat
a potential domestic threat and that's
why you're talking about the the Overton
window and you and you look at like okay
well you take people having open minds
and like okay well I can consider you
know someone else's perspective even if
I don't agree with it which is how
things should be in general
and then you take it to that next level
where you're saying well there are no
guard rails anymore and this is what's
so dangerous is is when you have
again people are entitled to their own
opinions but when you have people in
positions of power in this country who
deny the existence of objective truth
as they are then where where is like
where's the floor where's the guard
rails where's the ceiling how do you
measure anything well it's like okay
well whatever's true is whatever they
say is true
but then what happens when when they're
gone and the next person or group of
people come in or the next party and
then what if they don't agree with what
that group says is true or false and and
so um and then you couple that with the
Fear Factor and cancel culture and and
people literally seeing what happens to
people like me where you you just say
like hey well this is what's happening
and it's crazy it's insane and then I
get called all kinds of names and all
kinds of stuff uh all kinds of attacks
and so no wonder so many people are
afraid
to do the equivalent of like uh yeah
obviously the emperor has no clothes
like we can all see it and there's a lot
of concern about what's happening but so
few people feel like they have the
ability to speak up without being
worried about losing their job or being
shunned by friends or family members or
being like that crazy person
um and so this is this is kind of one
thing that's been that's been
interesting and and hope inspiring is is
you know I put out this this kind of
long and end up statement talking about
some of these very specific examples of
what's wrong with today's Democrat party
and I've been hearing from a lot of
people people I know a lot of people I
don't know in person on social media
people just saying like
like in a really serious and heavy kind
of way thank you for bringing voice to
the things that I've been feeling and
been frustrated with and but you know
haven't been able to give voice to
and uh so my hope is that you know the
more we speak up the more people feel as
though they can speak up and uh
yeah how do we protect people how do we
protect our freedoms that are under
attack by exercising them